hey that car is one of them alerts and
finds out it a black kid damn it I
helped them
[Music]
out you know about the Amber Alert right
yeah you're fan of them Amber Alert fan
I wish they had it when I was K that
right now yeah yeah dude amber alert for
sure what would you change about it if
you could change something like where's
the Amber I don't want them to disrupt
me when I'm watching a show that I like
oh okay oh yeah on your phone me later
when the show's done
and they're like what the [__] but I
think that's the point right I guess do
you think there's any ways that it can
be
improved cuz what did I tell you the
license plate or the car potentially
okay is alert like Nationwide or is it
just like local oh local local there's
both the most recent test was a
nationwide alert I think really that's
the one that we all got and everybody
got in the Amish people got in trouble
for having phones yeah oh that's
hilarious dude and a couple prisoners
what would I
change nothing dude how how how often do
you guys look at the amber alert and
then start looking for that [__] car
I do it in the vicinity and I go I one
time I thought I saw a [__] well now
that I shut up really now that I have a
kid but before I'm like [__] why what
made you think you saw cuz it was a
white Toyota Corolla and it was like
elderly someone got it was like a old
lady that got kidnapped or something
this was [__] falling up and [__] and
then I and I looked outside the window I
swear to God and I saw it like out of my
did you call the cop but I was trying to
look at the license plate and I was like
and did the driver go for a second shut
the [__] up do you yeah I would be
freaked out this gu [__] if you guys
actually saw the car would you do a
citizen's
arrest I would I would just call it in
hey I'm not trying to be that guy I'm
not a rogue yeah dude I [__] always
think about being a hero in situations
like that like after that I would be
thinking about like imagine if I catch
him and I grab him and I [__] pin him
down I call it comps and I'm like a hero
I can't one day because that's like you
could lowkey be a bully and then it's
not you're doing it for justice oh
Justice oh true yeah that's true cuz I
don't really care I just want to [__]
somebody up let's give a reason to [__]
someone up yeah that's how gun gun
owners feel wish somebody broke into
this house [__] give me a reason
to kill [__] there's one change
that they did make to the amember alert
I wouldn't say actually it's a change to
the amember alert they still going to
keep it exactly the way it is but
they've now added What's called the
ebony alert what's that ebony alert
don't like
and
I sorry so it just plays that song
instead of the
beat it's an eony ebony yes it's still
going to be the same sound like the you
know yeah they recently passed this new
law that creates the ebony alert it's a
basically the same system but it will
inform you if it's a black child that's
missing well that's racist what's the
difference yeah what's the difference a
child wait why do they need to do that
but what are they going to call an a for
people to be for people to be like this
a black guy oh well so if a is that what
that's going to happen some [__]
white people were going to be like no
it's all false
alarm is it cuz they want you to look
for a black girl or like a black kid I
don't here's the thing like it's hard to
tell if this is directly correlated to
what would be the solution for the
problem but the existing problem is that
they um like the black community feels
that there's less attention when it's a
black child missing that there's less
that's done about it is that true but I
thought Amber Alerts go for any missing
it does it does but now it's like emphas
think that when when an amber alert goes
off they're thinking of white kids so
then you're just looking for white kids
all day and you're like ah there's
nobody missing can can can I tell you
this why do I think that it's always
white kids like right now I just
realized like holy [__] I
never thought it was a Black or Mexican
I always thought it was always a white
kid do they even tell you the the race
cuz usually it's just the car right
isn't that what it is like it's it's the
car the color and then like the license
plate isn't that what people on the
lookout for anyway yeah mainly the car
mainly the car yeah cuz that's what the
well I don't know yeah at least that's
from what I it never gives a description
of the victim or like a picture or
nothing like changing the alert color
doesn't extra motivate me or less
motivate me to look around I'm cuz I'm
still looking just for the car if it's
like a Nissan Sentra red I'm like okay
yeah cuz if it's an ebony alert our
people are going to go oh it's a black
kid we better [__] actually go that's
what that's what I'm saying that's what
I'm saying what are they expecting we're
going to do I think it's what it says
here is that advocacy groups and policy
makers criticize the Amber Alert system
for overlooking missing children who are
black so there are they is there some
type of thing where if there was a
missing black kid they don't even do an
amber alert I think you will see Amber
Alerts for kids of different races but
what they're saying is that there's a
larger percentage of children that are
missing that are black but it doesn't
reflect in the alerts that go out if
that makes sense so isn't that a problem
is a problem problem yeah isn't that a
problem not with the color of the alert
but with the reporting system it might
be it it it could be yeah is this a
separate group that wants to specialize
in it or is it just like they're like
have a separate thing I think an ad a
separate advocacy group pitched or like
uh proposed this and California said
okay we'll do it of course California CU
California yeah I get it if like I get
California Vegas let's say like it dies
it dies let's say the black community
was like I need something we need
something of our own as an alert so they
have a group an organization that's
strictly going black kids missing all
right oh you know and then and then they
they're like their own uh Community I
don't think that's what it is oh never
mind I think that was a great rant
though that was a that would make that
would make sense right yeah that's what
makes sense it would it's like it's like
being a [__] a volunteer local fire
department or some [__] cuz you're like
there's no fire department in this
community and then so they specialize in
neighborhood watch yeah basically [__] I
I think it's also I could be wrong but I
feel like I read somewhere that ebony
alert applies to Children of color
generally so it might not just be black
just like
it might be like still an interesting
name yeah say it's targeting like the
racial disparity I think it's any kid
who's lost yeah we just send alert it's
like an alert let's just use Amber Alert
doesn't [__] matter the color it's
more like yeah cuz the problem isn't the
color of the alert the problem is are
they reporting more or alarming enough
like if there are 10,000 kids missing
are there 10,000 alerts right now it
seems like there's 10,000 kids missing
maybe only 500 alerts go out so let's
get the alert numbers up rather than
change the color yeah I don't know how I
feel about things being separated by
color it's making me feel more separated
yeah it really does like I get like they
need more people asking for more help
but it's like I feel it's making people
separate more but what what I don't get
is like in California right cuz this is
in California yes we have whole
neighborhoods of just black just Mexican
just Asian where the police the PO
politicians everybody is that so it's
like it's not like the 1950s where all
the cops are
and they're not giving to your community
like the people of your community are
running the so if there's like black
kids missing or whatever like I don't
think it's happening in white
neighborhoods usually people are living
in their own neighborhoods think about
that way where the cops and everybody
are you know people of your ethnicity
usually now but what if you're missing
from let's say you're a black child
missing from your black neighborhood and
they've now taken you out of that
neighborhood I don't even know how the
Amber Alert works but I don't know how
changing the color of the alert makes
that more more priority yeah I feel like
if it's just the Amber there everyone's
usually on the lookout just real quick
you know when you see the sign on the
freeway you go oh [__] it's a [__]
Sienna or whatever you look I don't know
any human being that would be like it's
black who cares or Asian orx or whatever
yeah that's [__] crazy ironically I I
believe those people might exist that's
what I'm saying
now you just gave those people an option
to be like I don't give a damn black kid
like you just gave him a voice to be
like yeah when it's Amber Alert he would
have been like hey that car is one of
them alerts and finds out it a black kid
damn it I helped them out cuz at the end
of the day it's just trying to identify
the vehicle yeah at this point if you
said it was an ebony alert I'd be
looking for a black
car cuz that's you know what I'm saying
it's true that it does make you're right
it does make more sense to not say what
you're looking for yeah because then
there's no Prejudice right how about
what are we going to do we we need our
own too as yeah we need to have one
like the Chingling or something
Chingling the Ringling dude into the
category of ebony alert though right if
that's meant to just be like a person of
color but we're not eony what is it
though what would it be that's what
that's what makes it strange is that
it's it's almost like oh here here's my
what I think it is I don't think it's so
much as a solution to the problem as is
trying to create awareness of the
disparity they just want people to know
that like 39% of kids that were missing
were black but the number of Amber
Alerts that went out were more swayed
towards like other races I think they
just want like the attention of like
check this [__] out now we got your
attention because they you know they
passed it oh yeah maybe from here they
can make a different solution to it but
for sure like we already know Common
Sense will tell you it's not going to
make more kids get rescued you specify
who's I think are you guys are you guys
a part of a ring Community just just the
other day you know how they're like they
they post [__] right there was a boy
just chilling there was like whose kid
is this and everybody you know how you
could comment right and everybody was
like call the cops and then the next
person whose boy is this oh man now you
know who lives in that house hey boy
scary dude I also think they Market if
that is the true cause they're marketing
to the wrong people they need to Market
to themselves cuz you know like when
Asians beat up remember when we're all
getting beat up yes we still are so
we're still getting beat up right when
we're getting beat up there's no point
in going like yo everybody stop beating
us up cuz we're still getting beat up
what actually worked it was like stuff
like Ron like you go to our community
hey don't walk around by yourselves
right this is what we're going to do so
we don't get beat up cuz the people that
want to beat us up are going to keep
beating us up so for those kids they
need to have their own support system in
that Community hey people are coming to
[__] take our kids and we need to
[__] stand up for ourselves or do
something about it versus hey everyone's
coming to take our kids but they're not
the perpetrators you know so you got to
like empower the people that are getting
[__] up and or getting the short end
of the stick protect the People by the
way I loved your PSA uh post that you
did for that when when the AG people
were getting [__] up B goes yo I'm
going to [__] you
up and I remember going like damn B
that's uh oh and that made me be like
you know what I'm going to I'm going to
not want to [__] up an Asian guy no more
that was it that was the one yeah so
everybody he did that I was like damn
he's that angry he's going to [__]
someone up angry I don't even remember
making a video you I'm going to beat
your [__] ass sub or something like
that and I was like wow I would never
see something like that oh so they do
they do provide a lot of stats that
backup that there is a problem that
maybe most people don't think about I
guess like the the I didn't know that
yeah I didn't know that either I guess
like there's a lot of more human
trafficking risks for some black kids
from certain communities and it's kind
of getting swept I mean it all sort of
gets swept on the road right I know like
but like this we didn't know about they
I heard the stat were like immigrant
kids too if they don't speak English and
whatever they're more um likely to get
stolen kidnapped and stuff yeah they
should make a Netflix documentary called
ebony alert and that's that's what's
going
to sure hit cuz it says that 40% of sex
trafficking victims identify as black
women
40% damn so what's the other 60 and did
you hear about how many kids miss are
missing from the border you know oh yeah
come across it's like okay we have like
10,000 kids that come through or
whatever and then it's like oh wait but
only 6,000 get documented where the
other 4,000 yep it's true I mean when
you look at what was that girl that um I
noticed this when when um remember that
girl the Gabriel or whatever that girl
that got lost in that van with her
boyfriend yeah poto poto remember that
yeah yeah yeah people recognize that
like crazy so cuz it's true because
honestly when when I see these things in
the news and Amber smart whatever right
or whatever all these girls that like
white blond girls yeah they it's true
they do it's a national conversation but
in my neighborhood when I was growing up
there was two [__] that got lost that
were Latinas and there were no National
so it's true they don't get was it on
Channel 34 was it on what was it on
Channel 3 tundo picked it up yeah tundo
America loves those stories especially
if it's a white blonde girl because I
think it it makes sense to like what
America kind of most so it's like they
could relate she also has a big
following too yeah and they're they're
influencers yeah but I think that's been
happening because it's like just human
nature to feel more relatable and closer
to people that look like you so that's
why they get all the attention but then
also that's not a good example of white
people that got saved
like they still both
died you know what I mean like they they
didn't try harder to help them they got
[__] both them it actually made it
made the investigation worse exactly
yeah it actually made it worse but then
here like I didn't know this statistic
it says that like out of all juvenile
prostitution arrests 57% are black whoa
wait juvenile arrest that's more than a
half yeah juvenile how are you going to
arrest a juvenile for being a hooker
when they're probably not doing it for
fun that's exactly yeah but that's the
[__] up they're a victim dude yeah for
sure like lock them up it really seems
like this is just like a big Beacon so
hopefully like something gets done that
has more action hopefully it doesn't
stop at this cuz obviously if this is
where it all ends it's kind of not going
to change I don't think so yeah best of
luck with whatever uh is next for this
more awareness yeah okay well I'll keep
a lookout
I turned mine off
[Music]
actually